[Musik]
hi leute ich hab euch auf instagram
gefragt was ihr sehen möchtet ein süßes
kürbis rezept muss daher und ihr habt
fast einstimmig geschrieben der american
pumpkin pie und computer in amerika zu
thanksgiving gemacht und das ist jetzt
gerade die zeit und ich finde wir können
auch davon profitieren auch wenn wir das
jetzt zum beispiel nicht feiern
es schmeckt einfach lecker ist nicht mal
einfach so sagen und ich mache jetzt
hier zuallererst mal den mürbeteig und
der besteht aus den folgenden
grundzutaten hier habe ich weizenmehl
zucker butter die ist kalt und in
stückchen geschnitten dann habe ich ein
ei und etwas salz für den mürbeteig
nämlich mit eine große schüssel gebe da
mehl zucker und die prise salz rein
anschließend in der mulde die kalte
butter und das ei und dann wird es zügig
mit den händen verknetet
[Musik]
mo
und jetzt den mürbeteig in folie
umwickelt und für 30 minuten in den
kühlschrank geben das bewirkt dass der
zucker sich auflösen kann und dass der
teig entspannt
jetzt habe ich mir meine tat formen
geschnappt und fette sie einmal mit
zimmer warme butter und streuseln mit
mehl aus das bewegt einfach dass wir
dann den pumpkin pie nach dem backen
richtig schön entfernen können ohne dass
da was an klebt
[Musik]
den kalkweg noch mal ganz kurz mit den
händen kneten so dass es einigermaßen
weich wird und dann zwei drittel davon
auf den boden der tat geben und das
restliche drittel an die seite pressen
dann solltet ihr alles schön ausgefüllt
haben was wir jetzt machen das auch ganz
wichtig wir nehmen uns eine gabel und
stechen damit auf dem boden damit der
teig auch nicht hochgeht beim button
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich die tat form bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
und dann zeige ich euch die leckere
kürbis füllung die zutaten für die
füllung sind auch sehr überschaubar ihr
braucht natürlich ein kürbis ich
persönlich nehme am allerliebsten in
hokkaido kürbis denn der ist
vollautomatisch und das tolle ist wir
können die schale mit verwendung müssen
wir nicht extra schälen des weiteren
habe ich hier noch die zutaten stehen
zucker für die süße natürlich dann etwas
schlagsahne
die habe ich getrennt eiweiß und eigelb
eine prise salz und etwas pumpkin pie
gewürzt jetzt mache ich mich zuallererst
an den hokkaido kürbis und ich werde ihn
jetzt fein würfeln
dann wird er schneller gar im wasser bei
mir dauert dann ungefähr 15 minuten und
anschließend können wir inspirieren
abkühlen lassen und weiter verarbeiten
und die kerne nicht wegschmeißen die
könnt ihr rüsten und dann vernaschen
[Musik]
so das kürbis muss ist fertig und das
ist auch ganz wichtig dass es abkühlt
denn wir geben jetzt noch ein gap dazu
und sahne und wenn das eben noch warm
werden wäre das nicht so förderlich
daher gebe ich das jetzt ins abgekühlt
kürbis muss also einmal ein gelb sahne
zucker und gerne auch schon das
champions weiß gewürz und werde das
nicht da hat dem schreibe ich unten in
die video beschreibung was ihr dann
ergänzend an gewürzen nehmen könnte
[Musik]
so die kürbis most hat ganz kurz nur an
die seite legen
wir machen jetzt mit dem eiweiss weiter
ich sage das jetzt mit der prise seit
einmal richtig schön steif einfach aus
dem grund weil die kürbis masse mir
sonst ein bisschen zu kompakt wäre und
das gleich in die kürbis masse
untergehoben ergibt dann so eine richtig
schöne cremige masse nach dem backen und
macht das ganze so ein bisschen leichter
[Musik]
die kürbis masse ist jetzt noch sehr
flüssig da dürft ihr euch nicht wundern
serviert während des backens ein wenig
fester aber dann ganz fest erst wenn sie
ausgekühlt ist deswegen backe ich das
ganze jetzt bei 175 grad ober und
unterhitze für 55 bis 60 minuten
lasst ihr das danach vollständig
auskühlen und am allerbesten über nacht
[Musik]
und wie ihr euren pumpkin pie dekoriert
ist natürlich euch überlassen ihr könnt
jetzt einfach puderzucker darüber geben
oder das ganze zusätzlich nochmal mit
frisch auf geschlagener sahne finden so
mache ich das total gerne und dann könnt
ihr auch schon ein stückchen genießen
schaut in die video beschreibung da
stehen alle genauen mengenangaben dann
könnt ihr euch einen screenshot machen
ab zu kaufland einkaufen und das ganze
nach backen und schreibt mir unbedingt
in die kommentare welches rezept ihr
gern als nächstes sehen möchtet ja dann
würde ich mal sagen bis zu meinem
nächsten rezepte auf die gis kitchen
jeans
[Musik]
da